let me tell you about super bowl 56 and
jd now out in hollywood i see jd and i
also see jonathan blitz who has followed
jd and has been uh recording jd
observing jd so oh yes he has yes he has
has it been interesting watching jd i
know you're not a huge football fan so
you weren't focused on the game you were
focused on jd the whole time yes i was
focused on jd watching football and it's
[ __ ] stressful the emotions get so
low with him
it's scary a little bit to me yeah what
helped with the stress was i had someone
sitting next to me every five minutes
asking me what direction each team is
going and who has the ball
well i need to know so in other words
the game blind can't follow the game so
he's asking you to sort of do the
play-by-play
is that good is that good wait it was
that good
i was caring about it [ __ ] the burrow
gets sacked and he's asking me wait was
that good that was good right and i'm
like no that was not good
what was it like for you the bengals
were winning with only 90 seconds left
in the game i mean it looked like they
were gonna win well first of all i felt
like an idiot because i basically cried
like three different times probably
multiple times whenever something like
really good happened i would start to
get emotional and be like i didn't like
compose myself but you mean sitting
there with blitz you started crying
yes i had to like stop myself i was like
you gotta get hold of yourself you look
ridiculous right now i can't believe he
was willing to do all of this in public
you know that stuff you do at home when
nobody else can see you is one thing so
when jd got out to hollywood right away
his big connection is ryan philippe the
actor he blew off jerry o'connell
um you know
jerry o'connell was pissed i i even was
he
yeah
here i'll play here's a voicemail this
is jerry o'connell being manageated he
offered his house to jd hollywood harmer
it's jerry o'connell um
guess you don't want to stay at our
house out here in los angeles if you
want us to uh leave you alone we're
gonna have a lot of fun hollywood harmer
we're gonna hit the gym we're gonna work
on our musculature
what the hell is it
have fun with it
so what happened when you got out to la
you guys took a plane out there i did
tell people when we flew that it was his
first time flying
he told every single person that we
would walk by yeah that it was my first
time flying even when we got off the
plane that was his first flight that was
his first flight i'm like stop it
[Laughter]
it started with the baggage claim lady
and she's like really what that's right
do you tell the baggage lady that in
fact it is not your first flight or yes
i say it's not my first flight this is
the stop it he's being stupid he needs
to go along with then we go through
security he's telling the security
person
we get to like our gate he's telling
people there and then we get on the
plane he's still in the flight attendant
then we sit down he's telling the people
sitting around
it was literally like non-stop i really
hope that they announced on the
loudspeaker that we have a first-time
flyer today his name is j.d harmeyer i
think on the way back i'm going to tell
them that it's our one year anniversary
as a gay couple and that it's his first
time flying that'll do it
i think yeah
maybe i'll announce it uh maybe i'll
propose to him oh i could do that i
could do something
i'm going to propose to him on the plane
look at me i see he'll do that i'm going
to get up and i'm going to be like i've
been in love with this man for so many
years i'm gonna get a ring also so i
already have a ring [ __ ]
so it's your fashion ring oh my gosh oh
i can't wait to do this no you're not
doing this oh i'm doing it i swear to
god dude
i'm dead look at me
can't stop the avalanche we're going on
separate flights i'm getting my flight
okay i'll change my flight too
yeah
now what about this dinner so when i
think of ryan philippe and the the good
looking guy and you know he's like a
hollywood leading man very good looking
they look good at dinner he was a very
good looking this guy is fantastic he is
like the coolest dude are women
constantly coming up to the table not
only attacking jd but uh attacking ryan
phillippe no
no people left us alone people people
left ryan alone um well some people did
not the people that worked there well
the waiter flipped out what do you mean
the waiter flipped out what did he do he
was blown away by jd he freaked out he's
like how are you at this restaurant what
is going on here he could give a [ __ ]
about ryan he was just
all about jd you know you could tell
that everyone recognizes jd whether they
go up to him or not or they feel the
energy not to approach um
but approach jd that's what i say to all
of jd fans make a bit of an effort if
you see him stop him on the street
give him a hug
don't give me a hug he loves hugs trust
me he loves this guy
john stop it if you see him i'm talking
to everyone who's listening if you see
jd make an effort stop him say hello
shake his hand give him a hug that's it
after the game michael rappaport the
famous hollywood actor immediately sent
a voicemail to jd uh and here it is you
filthy [ __ ]
hand job you
good
i hope you're [ __ ] crying tears of
misery you miserable four-eyed [ __ ] good
you
it's weird when he attacks you right i
mean um it's just out of nowhere like
he's not is he a rams fan all of a
sudden i thought he was a a giants guy
or what do you know i don't know what
his deal is i don't know why he wants me
to be miserable i don't know what this
is i have a picture here of a text jd is
congratulating michael rappaport on
being in only murders in the building jd
writes you're in only murders in the
building that is so awesome rapaport
writes back i'm going to spit in your
ass after this game peggy
that's my good friend michael rappaport
oh and then i guess you guys went on a
hike while you're out in l.a and jd was
all out of breath three miles he
couldn't do young man like that dude
it's all [ __ ] uphill i'm worried
about jd and his exercise let's i
haven't done it for a while but jesus
christ but you should do it i know what
i should do blit i know what i should do
but do it then i i will eventually when
i feel like it should be eventually it
should be nice now all right we don't
want to lose you jd you're an american
treasure i'm fine thanks that's true
he's very out of shape and he's getting
fat and it worries me
after the hike jd had a turkey club with
roasted potatoes and chocolate mousse
for lunch i mean that's a hefty lunch
for a big boy do you need moose for
dessert for lunch i wasn't looking for
dessert [ __ ] the [ __ ] here was
like forgot the dessert bring out the
dessert what about the fruit at the
dessert
dude you can't walk three miles listen
to jd's la height
a guy can barely function
john were you uh were you nervous for
him like like i was i was you know
nervous i mean i was a little nervous he
was very angry a pack of little dogs
beat him um
to the top the dog just beat you look
all these dogs are feeding you
what do you weigh these days i'm
probably like 2 20.
jesus what are you five five
[Laughter]
five eight
five eight
[Laughter]
i just wish he'd exercise more and then
he could enjoy all the food he wants to
eat he just has to have that motivation
to walk he doesn't walk he says i
haven't walked in three months
i mean like i haven't gone out like on a
like a regular walk to break a sweat
yeah i know i know i know i used to do
yep i'll get to it are you were you sore
after the big hike for three miles i was
irritated i was irritated in certain
areas that penis
i think the sack you know rubbing and
slapping up against the legs or
something i don't know
disgusting
shut up way to brag about your sack
i'm not paying attention to what's going
on i'd like to take you on another hike
jd before you i don't want to do another
hike i'm not doing that but you enjoyed
it after you you really i like the
accomplishment of it but i'm not looking
to do another hiking yeah we got j.d
what if he puts a cheeseburger at the
end of the hike will you do no shut up